time now for the press preview it's a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they come into us
in the next 20 minutes or so we'll check
out the headlines with the royal
historian professor
kate williams and the director of the
demos think tank
polly mckenzie good evening to you both
speak in a moment first of all let's
check out
those front pages for you starting with
the times
previewing prince philip's funeral
tomorrow with the simple headline the
queen
bids farewell
and the mirror goes with farewell my
love
the mail describes the private time the
queen will spend with her husband's
coffin before the procession
as one last moment with her prince
the telegraph quotes from remarks
expected to be given by the dean of
windsor as he conducts the service
with grateful hearts we remember the
many ways in which his long life
has been a blessing to us and prince
philip's legacy is reflected on front
pages across the country tonight
including uh here the yorkshire
post meanwhile the eye reports that
pregnant women are next on the priority
list for the kovhi vaccine
and the financial times understands
david cameron lobbied a senior german
government official on behalf of green
seal capital
at roughly the same time as an
investigation into the company's
german banking arm was intensifying
and as i said i'm joined tonight by
professor kate williams and polly
mckenzie great to see you both uh let's
start shall we
uh kate with the front page of the times
really lovely photo there in fact this
photo
on many of the front pages taken in 2003
by the countess of wessex a
grinning queen and her husband next to
her on a picnic rug
really just looking uh very content in
the scottish
sun's sunshine and kate this really is
an inside isn't it into how the queen
will remember philip yes that's exactly
right jonathan
and the royal families just as rhiannon
was just saying has been releasing
quite a lot of pictures of prince philip
from various periods of his life
on the social media i really think as a
way of trying to encourage us all
to as we allen was saying stay at home
but also to be part of the funeral by
looking at these pictures
and this is a very engaging informal
shot taken by the countess of wessex
of the two of them in 2003 this long
married couple who were nearly going to
be married for 74 years
and really i think reminds that it
wasn't just a business partnership but
he wasn't just ceo of the firm
it was also a love match right from when
the queen saw him
as a 13 year old girl they met before
but this was the first time she saw him
as a teenager
and all through that he's been beside
her as her strength so
it's just going to be very difficult to
say goodbye to him for her
yeah i'm polly i mean tomorrow will be
very difficult for the queen
she'll be sitting alone uh she'll be
wearing a mask
of course the one person she was allowed
to
be with in her bubble as it were during
the pandemic was the very person who
won't be there tomorrow
yeah and as we're seeing all this
coverage and the the details
you know that we've just heard from
rhiannon it's a reminder that
you know in the end they're just human
beings this is a family a family who are
mourning
a wife who is now a widow after you know
an extraordinarily long
marriage where you know and you know
they've
will have had ups and downs and rows and
arguments but
you know as you can see in this kind of
picture also an extraordinary love
and support for each other and and in a
way i think you know
those code restrictions are obviously
not what
uh philip would necessarily have wanted
or they would have chosen
but actually the the smallness of it the
intimacy of it
and you know as we're hearing that you
know this idea of having that the action
stations
that idea that prince philip would have
wanted us to
to mourn him to celebrate his life but
also to move on
uh in service of the country as well
well it's the same photograph on the
front of the
daily telegraph of the
the royal couple and kate we have heard
more detail
about the order of service tomorrow the
tribute to philip
will include the words courage fortitude
and faith and interestingly as rhiannon
was telling us there'll be no eulogy
and there'll be no readings from the
family
why is that do you think yes i think
people were expecting to perhaps hear
some images some readings from family
members they're often
really very emotional parts of the
funeral will remember of course elle
spencer's
uh reading eulogy at princess diana's
funeral
but certainly it seems to be the case
that prince philip wanted
his his family and of course the queen
to not to have the stress i think of
being part of reading and giving eulogy
and really to speak much more through
music it's really fascinating how
so many of these hymns are very
significant i i'm really fascinated by
by one of the hymns just chosen is a
funeral hymn in the russian and greek
orthodox churches
which reminds us that philip was born
into the greek orthodox church he was
part of the greek war family
had to flee when he was 18 months old
because of a coup
and also that he was related to the
russian royal family
who were deposed and shot and in fact
interestingly phillips dna was
used to identify the russian war family
many years later
or descended from queen victoria and
really it reminds us that as a child
as a baby and before he was born philip
saw so many of these royal families
families crumble and be in the most
violent of circumstances and when he
came into the british royal family
he both had to leave so much of that
behind but he had to be rebaptized into
the anglican church
but also had to really take those
lessons i think
into strengthening the british royal
family after seeing so many european
monarchies fall and i think above all
it's reminding us that even though he
would be
that he would get buried with his
in-laws and eventually the queen one day
that he also was part of another family
and
they are very very so important to his
life along with his naval background
which is also commemorated
yes it's interesting you mentioned that
um there'll be no sermon
polly but uh throughout the service his
love of the sea
and the navy will be reflected
yeah it's clear that he really had a
hand in planning this funeral
with all of those those personal touches
i love the idea of this land rover a
specialized land rover
to carry the coffin um yeah i sort of
imagine him tinkering away
with a spanner trying to get it fixed up
but i think in fact he was more of a
more of a kind of overseer of the
project but you know it it really is a
personal funeral for
a man a human being a husband more than
it
is something for uh you know the nation
even though of course he was a symbol of
something to all of us
i know the more we hear about the
details of this the more it feels like
they are wanting to you know claim a
moment
as human beings they have given a life
of um of public service and
in a way they need a moment for
themselves of course funeral is
something that all families at some
stage
have to deal with uh kate let's look at
the front page of the daily mail
um they have uh an interesting detail
the queen will say a private farewell to
prince philip
before his coffin leaves windsor castle
uh for the funeral one last moment
with her prince um the queen's
remarkable
dignity will be on display uh once again
yes the queen will have a private
farewell to prince philip before his
coffee and leaves windsor castle
he's in the private chapel in windsor
castle where he actually designed
a window in there after windsor castle
burnt down
and there will also be this what we will
also see is that when
she'll be in she won't be walking she'll
be in a procession in the bentley her
children walking her three
male adult grandchildren william harry
peter phillips
she'll be in a bentley with the lady and
waiting but the bentley will also pause
in front of the land rover which is
bearing phillips coffin
so that the queen can have one last
moment to witness and and be with philip
before he goes into the chapel and then
of course after the end of the service
we'll go down
to the royal vault so this is her moment
with philip
and it's really so important to remember
as just as you were saying that
they have been bubbling together this
whole year due to the pandemic
philip was in sanjing where he retired
at wood farm they came together
in windsor castle spent christmas
together usually a huge rural occasion
was just the two of them and his final
days she has been there by his side so
she has been able to give him a real
farewell discuss plans for the funeral
discuss plans for
the future but this is her final
farewell to him and i think it's very
moving
to commemorate that indeed kate
polly thank you for the moment coming up
after the break fresh allegations
concerning david cameron's involvement
in the green seal lobbying controversy
we'll discuss that next
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me professor kate
williams and polly mckenzie polly let's
uh take a look at the front of the
ft the cameron sleaze allegations
continue this is quite an interesting
take isn't it that david cameron
pitched the services of green hill
capital to a senior german
government official yeah i mean david
cameron has not had
a great week in terms of controversy
because green sale
ended up going bankrupt uh every single
bit of his activities with green cell
has now coming under scrutiny
you know unsurprisingly he has strong
connections with uh
german senior government officials after
being prime minister for six years
so he was according to the ft leveraging
some of those connections in
a phone call trying to encourage uh the
rollout of green sales earned product
which is basically allowing people to
draw down some of their
earned wages before payday which
actually is quite a good idea quite a
good product
other providers on the market but trying
to get that rolled out in the civil
service
in germany as he had uh successfully got
it
introduced in various parts of the uk
public service and of course once the
business has collapsed that
looks like a disastrous thing to have
done the reality is
trying to make a life after politics
we're having younger and younger prime
ministers it seems
through history and and this question of
what do you do for the 40 years after
you've been prime minister
it turns out almost everything you can
do is uh a quagmire of political
controversy
yeah i'm just staying with you polly and
very quickly because i want to get
kate's thoughts on this i mean it
doesn't feel
like any rules have necessarily been
broken
but it does suggest that the rules
perhaps need to be changed
it's got echoes of the expenses scandal
hasn't it
yeah the question of of uh using your
connections and your position in order
to
uh secure advantage for your you know
private enterprise
you know feels feels uncomfortable on
the other hand
what is it that we expect our prime
ministers to do they can't
stop knowing all the people that they've
met in their lives they can't we can't
not
give them a job um you know nick clegg
has quoted his controversy who i used to
work for
by going off to work facebook which you
know again controversial but
if you're gonna if you stop being in a
high public office at the age of 50
are you supposed to just live in
retirement forever so i think in a way
we've created a sort of an existential
uh dilemma for ourselves with
with the fact that so many political
careers just end in
you know disaster a little bit too early
um kate what are your thoughts on this i
mean
it's not playing massively uh in terms
of the polling in fact you govern
putting the conservatives 14 points
ahead
of labour well there i mean i think
greetings
is deeply problematic i think that
cameron's obviously involvement in this
and i think that his initial
introduction into everything to the
civil service was the jeremy hayward the
idea that you could
wait longer to pay suppliers because
surely if anyone in the country has
liquidity it's government and if they
are taking if they can't pay suppliers
this doesn't need privatizing so i think
it was problematic from the beginning
but i also think that there are a series
of important corruption stories there
are questions about boris johnson's
behavior our mayor of london
there are questions about what has
happened to some of the health contracts
and these are ongoing at present and i
think these are also things we should be
looking at obviously
the most recent stories about matt
hancock and
his sister's his uh his sister's company
but certainly
i think i could i mean i see what paul
is saying that what are they going to do
what are they going to do when they
finish in politics but there just seemed
to be a huge amount of money going on in
here with cameron
and the amount of money he stood to bear
he wasn't just helping business here he
was a serious amount of shares he stood
to
bring from and to try and bring it into
other civil servants as well
so i think it's very right that this is
investigated
but i think that other parts of the
corruption and other parts of these
contracts that really don't seem to have
been given out for pretender
all of them should be investigated and
sometimes it seems to me that for the
conservative party green seal is quite a
good distraction
from what they could be also accused of
doing at present themselves
i just think this story has got some way
to go yet
kate and polly uh for now thank you
we'll see you again in half an hour so